hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
I'm John so December 5th currently don't
have access to the channel they leaked
our email back to a channel that was not
our channel no there's some great bar
mitzva there's some awesome bar mitzvah
videos I've only got 19 subscribers
right now promote the crap out of that
yet we wanted to give a shout-out to our
sponsor
Stardust arduous Stardust has been a
really kind company to us and you know
what they have a great service a great
app where you can do 30-second reactions
for any film TV show or trailer we're
almost at 2,000 followers people's to
2,000 seconds of reaction it's really
great and I've been using it more now to
even just talk about random films that
just pop it in my mind like wah wah Wes
and everything but you know of course we
use it mainly for really when we catch a
movie and we do a quick review of it I
think this is from this is up to 20
minutes on Google Translate as well as
countless hours watching telenovelas
that's right but I think this is sexy
red spandex Portuguese komma shok easy
to judge a mulatto
is comprised of it
nobody pushed another a saucier
dispenser is simply a logical address
I've been teaching Ruby
Mitchell Falacci of sewing okay how
about this is on five cotton was there a
saintly mo kawaru QT emoji data what are
you waiting for go to the website below
to reserve your spot and you're sure to
talk real thing you agree there's
nothing like a wild day or night in
Brazil to make a special movie that
you'll cherish forever
just ask the 2016 US men's swimming team
they'll probably make some [ __ ] up dude
we're going to Brazil getting tattoos
Brazil Brazil I'm so happy that one
thing that has been worried that had me
a little worried about what they would
do with Deadpool - it was all that the
you know the dispute that was going on
between Ryan Reynolds and Tim Miller
I can't remember who was the one who's
like I want to keep it Deadpool E and
one wanted to go bigger I think that was
Tim Miller who was like I want to go
bigger which would make sense if he
likes which is the terminator old Indian
out so I'm glad that would the marketing
they're reassuring us I think no we're
just keeping it the Deadpool fashion
your life we're not gonna do like cool
trailer 40 trailer thing I'm just gonna
action we're gonna do the the funny
marketing now they were known for for
the first step pull which made it such a
big hit and now they're keeping that
tradition going
and I hope they never change that
because that's what maysa movies so
special is doing non-traditional things
well yeah we all fell in love with
Deadpool's personality manner from the
marketing
like I like like you I like that they're
continuing this trend of making these
wacky viral videos and doing stuff like
this I mean I'm sure that a lot of fans
are gonna turn up and yeah and and you
know get inked it's at the point where
Deadpool does so many random from
promotional videos this could just be a
video you have to be for Deadpool to
feel like every few months we just have
Deadpool show up on YouTube say he kind
of does that already yeah yeah even when
they weren't making Deadpool 2 it just
makes appearances I don't love marketing
but I do enjoy whatever the folks behind
Deadpool are doing all right well I
can't wait for Deadpool to yes my Thanos
man it's gonna be crazy
my Thanos man he's gonna save and then
kill the MC you think Deadpool vs. the
Punisher
oh my god clash of tones that would be
funny that would be funny you take the
Deadpool tone and throw the Punisher in
there or you do the Punisher tone any
throw Deadpool in there I think it will
be way more dreary if you took the
Punisher tone and threw Deadpool in yeah
yeah and then you can make Deadpool kind
of a villain or you do the exact flip
ideas people Hollywood that's why they
call me Greg the only villain that Frank
Castle actually fights simply because
he's getting on his nerves to the real
rejects right we have a new tradition
now getting up videos extremely late yes
got to continue that tardy train keep it
rolling follow us on the Stardust app
download the app follow us there's a
unique URL in the description box become
a patron eject today it's the second
youtube channel essentially didn't plan
on that but that's what it's become it's
like a second channel that's more
freeform raw and so yeah you get
pictures a lot of my videos it's really
fun it's really fun having a
uncircumcised who that's how I did it
myself